I don't think a Putin targeted Hillary
Clinton specifically certainly not in
the outset of the elections the idea was
to undermine the trust in the very
institution of us election whether it's
on the Republican side the Democratic
side or local side a federal side that
did not start with the u.s. elections it
happened with Russia's involvement all
over Western Europe and Eastern Europe
but as things progressed and it became
clear that that Hillary Clinton was
going to be the nominee of the
Democratic Party and especially since
she became the leading candidate it was
particularly sweet for Putin to attack
her because there is bad blood between
them in 2011 when mass anti-putin
demonstrations swept throughout Russia
he blamed the State Department for
organizing and paying for those
demonstrations and Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State so what do you think
about Russian involvement in the u.s.
presidential election let us know in the
comments section and also let us know
what other topics you want AI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds